qui avait été souvent arrêtés on va le
dire sinon on a connu fois répondu oui
mais une fois c'est ce qu'on sait vous
inquiétez pas je l'avais même où j'ai
tous les dos s'il vous plaît vous vous
n'êtes pas un jour enfermé dans votre
voiture
enfermez vous ici on va regarder
pourquoi je vous confirme innovation
gariche pas un enfant d'été vous avez
réglé dès que la vérité vous conseillons
de l'éclat sans permis comment vous
conduisez hamouma sans permis comme ça
c'est pas pour ça je me suis enfermé
dans une voiture où qu'ils aillent pas
oui c'est vrai oui c'est vrai ou pastis
la rixe et hop voilà sans permis voilà
du coup j'ai fermé les fenêtres et il me
retrouvera est déjà cible est à côté moi
c'était la vie plutôt qu'à la vitre et
tu auras pas ouvert mais non on n'aura
pas ouverts qu'ils appellent à luna vrai
ou pas mais qui étaient ces régions qui
perd tout cela ce qui se bat à
[Applaudissements]
mais palissier tu t'appelles adepte du
gard et l'autre était enfermé il voulait
pas ouvrir et qui fait ce à quoi est-ce
que vous êtes déjà fait arrêter par la
police qu'il ya eu déjà un moment vous
dans votre vie où vous vous êtes dit je
vais aller ce que vous allez dire tu es
de la garde à vue
par exemple ici au tour auto la table
thierry moreau 40 heures ces 30 heures
de garde à vue vous avez volé en mars
dans une affaire de blanchiment d'argent
mais j'ai été blanchi
awe blanchiment d'argent et sont venus
me chercher le matin à 6 heures
maintenant ils ont offert par votre
porte comme paris par toutes les entrées
de la maison non mais vous avez vu que
c'est poli vous aviez su tout de suite
c'est le désarmer tout non c'est pas
vrai vous étiez en slip non non je n'y
habite pas ce que moi je me pose
toujours la question sans décoller s'il
ya un mec qui arrive la nuit c'est
toujours sur leurs routes se battre tout
nu non mais tu vois même le masque du
vote qu'après qu'un match peut attendre
deux minutes je met un petit pantalon
trop petites missions on se tape après
n'inquiète pas mais juste là bas j'ai
pas me taper tout nu c'est relou vous
avez eu des problèmes avec la police
moi je me suis toujours elle en avait on
s'en fout parce que si c'est pour nous
dire moi je me suis toujours très bien
entendu avec la police j'appelle ma mère
mélina alors justement alors s'il ya une
anecdote
oui une anecdote sur quoi sur la sur le
national la livre sur la maréchaussée
harry moi j'ai toujours eu de bons
rapports avec m un soir on parle de rtl
jason berken avec celui très vite trop
vite pour moi
il le sait et donc brusquement se fait
courser par les flics mais l orge en a
déjà été arrêté par des parts d'etf
livre pour les tout petits excès de
vitesse de mon mari mais là vraiment on
sentait qu'il ya d'autres choses ils
sont mis en travers ils l'ont sorti de
la voiture il en connaît mes mains sur
le capot voulions pc son pote à moi je
demandé
il faut caresser les cheveux l'ombre
c'est à la fin vous avez pas les
policiers afin qu'ils avaient un
signalement d'un mec qui est un
trafiquant de drogue qui s'enfuyait et
alain veyret mon mari avait la même
voiture
donc il a fondu ou la façon dont ce qui
conduisait vite et dont il avait le
sentiment qu'ils voulaient leur échapper
bon et le mec il vient vers moi ça me
questionner c'est d'écouter alors moi
vous faites ce que vous voulez avec lui
n'a rien à [ __ ]
ils roulent trop vite et tout et tout et
le mec il me faut les flics ils vous
regardent vers paris lui il va vers mon
mari il lui dit oulala sens que vous
allez avoir des ennuis à la maison vous
avez déjà assez de problèmes comme ça
mon pauvre en malaisie non ils ont ils
m'ont laissé partir comme ça ah ouais
mais tous préféré une autre anecdote
voulait avant-hier voir une course je me
suis fait j'ai pu passer orange en
scooter ce qui est pas bien il attendait
juste de l'autre côté donc il me font
des sons du scooter me font monter dans
la camionnette et commence à rédiger le
truc est minime et ils vont ont permis
des courbes et julien courbet séries tu
ne viendra jamais qu'à côté tu
deviendras pas ouais c'est julien combes
et par là les temps les bonjour madame
oui effectivement c'est julien courbet
votre mari est sympa l'a aidé voilà ok
je merci moi aussi madame il me fait
plus tard est incroyable on en est et où
[Applaudissements]
si jamais si ça va je la rappelle